eric sinclair bonjour bonjour merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation ce
matin sur rtl france donc pour revenir
sur ces annonces du gouvernement avec en
premier lieu à l'instauration du pass
vaccinale dès lundi annoncé par le
gouvernement sauf sauf avis contraire du
conseil constitutionnel alors un avis
contraire est-ce que cela reste possible
possible tout est toujours possible
c'est très très peu probable legault le
conseil constitionnel manifestement et
a renoncé à s'attacher comme ils
devraient au liberté fondamentale et
notamment à l'article 5 de la
déclaration des droits de l'homme qui
stipule que nul ne peut être contraint
de faire ce que la loi ne donne pas
le conseil national manifestement ne va
pas tenir compte de son précédent ta vie
au mois de juillet où il disait que si
ç'avait été le pass sanitaire une
obligation vaccinale déguisée alors à ce
moment là il n'aurait pas pu la valide
et là il se trouve que son étude ça a
été affirmé par le ministre de la santé
olivier ferrand c'est donc clairement
annoncée par le gouvernement et les fort
probable malgré tout que le
le conseil constitutionnel valide
néanmoins 7,7 cette obligation vaccinale
déguisée au mépris des libertés
fondamentales qu'il a normalement
l'obligation de protéger alors c'est au
moment où la france n'a jamais eu un
taux de contamination si elle devait
finalement que l'exécutif annonce
l'allégement de certaines restrictions
les a vus est ce que cela veut dire
alors que c'est la fin de la stratégie
du test que l'exécutif mise tout sur le
pass vaccinale
cetc pour honnêtement pour les pour les
français décrypter cette séquence
ça doit être un peu compliqué si l'on
écarte l'accusation de cynisme
politicien
et qu'on cherche une stratégie
réellement cohérente en matière en
matière sanitaire vous venez de le
préciser on est encore au niveau du pic
de l'épidémie même s'il est probablement
passé avec plus de 300000 contamination
par jour et des mesures de restriction
des jauges des fermetures pour les
discothèques par exemple qui ont été
annoncées qui manifestement n'ont servi
à rien hélas aujourd'hui une réouverture
une suppression des jauges alors que
nous sommes encore en pleine épidémie
les français doivent se demander mais
qu'est ce qu'est ce qui se passe mais
voilà l'explication est extrêmement
simple le variant au micron qui est
aujourd'hui largement majoritaires dans
notre pays ne provoque chez la majeure
partie des personnes vaccinées ou pas
d'ailleurs que des rhinites et donc
finalement il est complètement anodin il
est dangereux encore pour une certaine
catégorie de personnes ces personnes là
devraient être vaccinés aujourd'hui
c'est leur choix encore une fois le
gouvernement lui est pris dans une
logique politique à trois mois des
échéances présidentielles il ne veut pas
se dédire donc ils essayent de faire
croire aux français qu' un calendrier de
confinement et de déconfinement ou
plutôt de contraintes et de relâchement
des contraintes qui est un calendrier au
niveau du pas salutaire et que ce
relâchement des contraintes est au
bénéfice du pass vaccinale désormais
validé à partir de lundi mais la réalité
c'est que l'ensemble des pays européens
sont une stratégie différente et que là
la france est en retard d'une guerre une
fois encore oui parce que certains
attendent effectivement la levée de ce
pass vaccinale olivier vers ans a été
interrogé il a assuré je vais le site et
qu'il sera appliquée autant que
nécessaire mais pas plus que nécessaire
donc l'exécutif encore floing sur la
durée de cette mesure la levée du pass
vaccinale pas du tout à l'ordre du jour
finalement mais non pas du tout à
l'ordre du jour et encore une fois on
est on est dans une stratégie tout à
fait particulière en france on a eu si
vous vous rappelez bien pendant la
première année au moins de lait kid émis
une cohérence assez forte entre la
parole des médecins principalement des
infectiologues et puis des responsables
de services d'urgence ou de réanimation
dans les principaux hôpitaux français et
la parole du gouvernement c'est à dire
que certains médecins n'étaient pas
d'accord aurait aimé une stratégie
différente mais quand même sur le vaccin
sur la protection sur les gestes
barrières on sentait que la parole
médicales étaient en appui des mesures
gouvernementales en tout cas dans les
premiers mois sur la première vague et
puis plus le temps a passé plus les
paroles médicales ont commencé à se
séparer de la parole gouvernementale
aujourd'hui nous sommes dans une
situation tout à fait particulière où la
majeure partie des infectiologues qu'on
entend sur les plateaux télévisés sont
en rupture nette avec la parole
gouvernementale et 10 le pass vaccinale
ne sert à rien pour gérer l'épidémie
pour endiguer l'évolution de au micron
et pourtant le gouvernement 500 têtes et
pourtant le gouvernement continue de
prétendre s'appuyer sur une position
scientifique
les scientifiques aujourd'hui qui sont
en faveur de la position gouvernementale
sont extrêmement minoritaires donc la
question qui se pose c'est pourquoi le
gouvernement continue de s'entêter ainsi
et vous n'avez pas d'élément de réponse
à ce jour et non à part la question
assez cynique politicienne que j'ai
écarté au début de mon raisonnement et
qui consiste à dire et bien puisqu'on ne
veut pas perdre la face et puisqu'on
veut laisser penser aux français que
nous avons bien géré la crise jusqu'au
bout et que nous allons traverser cette
crise grâce à toutes les mesures qui ont
été prises eh bien nous allons continuer
dans sa stratégie de l'antenne pas en
espérant que notre électorat ne se
rendent pas compte que nous avons fait à
peu près n'importe quoi depuis les
masques et les tests en mars 2020
jusqu'à la stratégie du pass vaccinale
qui complètement inutile de la vie même
encore une fois c'est pas le politologue
qui parle de l'avis même des
infectiologues des grands hôpitaux
parisiens que ce soit la salpêtrière que
ça soit à l'hôtel dieu à paris que ce
soit liée à celle du professeur out
partout se passe vaccinale est décriée
merci beaucoup frédéric saint clair
d'avoir accepté notre invitation ce
matin sur rtl france je le rappelle vous
êtes éditorialistes cologne